[موسيقى]
كانت تغريدات تويتر تنهمر مثل المطر غزيره
ومن كل اتجاه وكانت المظله التي تحمينا من
المعلومات المغلوطه هي علامه التحقق
الزرقاء لكن هذه العلامه اصبحت بقياده
ايلان مصر رمزا للعار حتى ان بعض الشركات
رفضت استخدامها رغم ان ماسك قدمها لها
مجانا
[موسيقى]
منذ ان استلم الملياردير ماسك شركه تويتر
وهي في تغيير مستمر تاركه للمشتركين في
حيره ازاء مصير حساباتهم علامه التحقق
التي تم اطلاقها عام 2009 اختفت من حسابات
نشطاء وعلماء وصحفيين لم يدفعوا الرسوم
الشهريه بينما وثقت العلامه الزرقاء صفحات
شخصيات غير معروفه تدفع الرسوم
ظهور واختفاء العلامه الزرقاء من عده
حسابات خلال الاسابيع الماضيه اربكان
مستخدمين فقد استعادت الحسابات الكبرى اي
التي لديها اكثر من مليون مستخدم العلامه
الزرقاء بينما قال ماسك انه دفع رسوم بعض
المشاهير للحفاظ على علاماتهم وقد تختفي
العلامه لبضعه ايام اذا تم تغيير الصوره
الشخصيه لكنها تعود للحسابات المدفوعه بعد
التاكد وتنعم هذه الحسابات بميزات خاصه اذ
يمكن لتغريداتهم ان تكون اطول والدعايات
التي تظهر لهم اقل بنسبه 50%
[موسيقى]
علامه التحقق الزرقاء التي باتت من حق
الحسابات المدفوعه سواء لاشخاص او شركات
لا تعني اي شيء غير ان الحساب لمشترك في
المنصه وتم التحقق من رقم هاتفه
[موسيقى]
فهل سيتغير نشاط المنصه مع الوقت من تفاعل
وتغريد من قبل المستخدمين وهل سيقبل البعض
استعاده علاماتهم الزرق بالمال هذا ما
ستكشفه لنا الايام لصباح العربيه هند
ابراهيم واشنطن
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات